today's video is sponsored by surf shark
[Music]
a rare super bloom of poppies is
blanketing southern california
thousands of people are showing up every
day to get a glimpse
it's just the third time it's happened
in the last 12 years
we do have a lot of habitat damage from
people going on the small trails on the
sides to take pictures of the flowers
gene ryan has spent 13 years at antelope
valley california poppy reserve talking
to visitors about wildlife
we need everybody's cooperation for the
habitat to survive this season
thank you
normally she gives educational tours but
these days she's busy policing a new
pest
[Music]
while taking a picture seems innocent
california poppies are fragile and can
be destroyed easily
this park was created specifically
because of the poppies that are here and
if they get stepped on or sat on to take
a picture in it that kills the one
purpose of this park
so this is what happens when people go
off trail it starts off as a small trail
and then other people think that since
somebody else already stepped there it's
okay for them to walk out there
we get people who just think they can do
whatever they want and
we'll talk to them and tell them what
they're doing wrong
they don't care
if they're damaging the habitat they
just want their picture
well if people post a picture on
instagram or facebook and they tag us
and it has them sitting in the flowers
we'll write a note on it
park officials created the hashtag don't
doom the bloom to educate influencers
but it's not stopping anyone nearly 150
000 posts are tagged superbloom
we're covering why
instagramers are stupid
yeah the only thing that's important is
the me me that's what
the point of that is
yeah it's just interesting sometimes
when you see like at the expense of the
very thing that they're photographing
it's just interesting like um it was
never about that thing it's like the
lady that was pausing for black lives
matter like she was helping
then she got back in her car and it's
not about it yeah i remember that's how
i go during the protest she got in front
of the business and she's holding up a
black lives matter thing and she got
back in her car right after and just
yeah as if they were boarding things
yeah
it's the exact same thing it's the exact
same ammo it's not about what's going to
happen it's about me i look cool cause
i'm doing that i find it so unbelievably
cringe
when i'm out of an event like let's say
it's a music event hip-hop realty
and you'll see like these girls come in
and they don't give a [ __ ] about the
event they take their picture with
whoever's in the background yeah and
then you just leave yeah and i'm like
if they had a pass they don't give a
[ __ ] exactly but my whole point is
sometimes they take up the spot of
somebody who actually wanted to enjoy it
but for this social currency yeah they
came in there just so they can be on
social currency just so they can be on
social media being like i was there
i wanted to be part of the movement or
whatever i put a black square on
instagram i'm such a good person yeah
and there's a lot of that and this one's
coming at the expense of nature itself
which is like to them yeah it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter to them it's
just like
maybe like uh yeah i'm gonna be that guy
you know when you go to a concert and
you film the concert
[ __ ] you dare
experience it
no i need memories preaching i need
memories yeah i got an application for
that it's called memories
i tell all my friends we're not taking
pictures when we go out and if you are
you do it on your cross my friends don't
take pictures so i'm grateful we go out
we enjoy ourselves and then we talk
about it when we need to relive it i
don't need to share with everyone on
instagram but some people are so caught
up it's like i'm doing a story
based nobody cares that people it's not
that deep nobody cares about your father
but you want to look interesting online
and your lifestyle and what you do and
all this especially if you don't make
money of it you're just like
a normal person
which mind you we all are on top of that
it doesn't even benefit you
put your phone down
posing
phone down and the posing too look where
i'm at i'm going to show y'all what i uh
the cringe
i always got to take pictures of [ __ ]
selfies just [ __ ] remember it you got
two functioning eyes and a [ __ ] brain
you actually make stronger memories when
you're really physically and mentally
proud yes you know instead of spending
so much time trying to take the picture
actually experience what it is that
you're trying to enjoy you know so many
people want to take pictures with like
little african kids why don't you
actually spend time actually talking to
them and understanding how useless your
your your bricklaying for this school
actually is becky you know i'm saying
like at some point he's like did you
just come here to shoot a video are you
here to dance that's basic some people
just came to shoot a video they didn't
come here to dance and so you ruined the
whole point of the experience which is
visceral in order to catch it in a still
frame you have to understand you're
talking about movement you're talking
about experience you're talking about
connection with other people you don't
catch that in the photo you know
motherfucker's gonna be like oh my gosh
i have such a good memory no
i don't yeah i actually
don't have that much of a good memory
you know how i know he reminds me all
the time
i don't have that much of a good memory
but for those certain things i was there
i was not only watching them things i
was feeling them i go to a concert i'm
there i'm looking at the people there's
the smells the look everything the
temperature all of that i'm there my
memory is not that good but i'm just
there she gotta go through your photos
and [ __ ] it's just cringe
unfortunately today's video is sponsored
by surf shark vpn so vpn is basically an
application or web extension that you
could use on your web browser or on your
internet to mask your ip address
basically hiding your location from
whatever website you're interacting with
now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you based off of
your ip address and so if you're trying
to view online content the online so
download certain things based off where
you live those things could be
restricted now i like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and when that happens
basically i use a vpn to be able to
bypass that so i can watch what i want
to watch because i feel like the
internet's at its best when everything's
accessible if you use promo code abba
and preach you get 83 off plus three
months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers you
deserve to go wherever you'd like to go
except if you want to physically fly
then buy yourself a plane ticket it's
just unfortunate because the people who
are beside you rather than joining and
living a moment with you have to be
robbed of that because you want to take
a picture or have to look away you know
uh people do that with their kids too
it's like you'd rather be able to show
your kids on instagram than just being
present with them in that moment why am
i seeing your kid online pet peeves to
keep the kids offline pet peeve go for
it we're having a good moment we chill
in all right let's see we had a bar we
have a good moment we're chilling
you cut me off
to take a picture
i can't appreciate it though [ __ ] me
right i appreciate i can understand that
fans
seeing us for the first time you want to
take a picture but you know we're trying
to live in that experience too that
conversation that we're having that
individual you know sometimes we don't
want to have to break that so we can
give you your picture sometimes we want
to just be present with the person that
we're with
you know i'll tell you like a moment
that kind of peeves me and i don't think
the guy meant it
so no no no disrespect to him but
i get out of the train station i haven't
seen my mom like six months so i'm kind
of excited and my mom's like standing
across from me you know she's lost some
weight she looks great i haven't seen
her so i'm so happy for her and i'm just
excited to go and see her and on my way
to walk towards my mom so it's like yo
abba can i get a picture i said no and
there was like a little bit of sadness
on the dude's face but like
at my mom and i'm like i want to see my
mom right now i ain't seen her and you
can't take that away from me and as much
as i may love you the fans and all that
good stuff i want this moment for myself
because i've been waiting for it for a
long time now so i could take a picture
and not talk i'd be like hey everybody
look just i could be present with the
person sometimes i think people
completely abandon those things and
rather than try to make memories they
try to make photo albums
but photo albums only matter because
they're memories that's why digital
photos that you have on facebook from
years ago nobody gives a [ __ ] you don't
even give a [ __ ] most of y'all never
looked through half the photobombs you
used to make your old ass instagram
posts nobody cares
right
so spend less time doing that [ __ ]
i guess that's the only thing i could
say it's this whole online [ __ ] your
stories it's it's not important
it's really not important
especially if you're taken away from
being present somewhere
you know
i'll take pictures with fans but the
minute i get kids and you see me with
kids
leave me alone
[Music]
the look that we're going for
like hunger games realness almost you
know
um so i was kind of going for
a fairy-esque
90s grunge cloud person
so we came out here because i wanted to
get into more doing stuff that was more
outdoorsy in l.a because i being
downtown you don't do it as much
kind of like the photos of being one
with the earth and kind of being more
[Music]
natural let me just be one with the
earth and be natural posting it on my
phone
this is why i judge people based off of
what they post on instagram
you really laid in those flowers to take
that shitty ass picture
god
maybe that's me and maybe that's unfair
maybe it's too judgey i don't know but
deadass bro if i go on some instagram
and they got corny photos like that i'm
like you must lack self-awareness
you must you know what i'm saying like
there's signs telling you you're killing
nature and you would still go there to
just take a picture that's basic that's
super basic to this basic
that's crazy basic but
kind of you know blending in almost like
seeing seemingly like you're coming out
of the ground with the flowers emma's a
model so we decided to grab some ig
shots
some of the classic look
i think what pulls people in is like
just wanting to have that kind of
magazine moment you don't have to run
out of studio yeah you don't have to
rent out a studio you have to kill the
nature you're so much better than the
people who do the big magazine shoots
you just have to kill the environment
appreciate you just have a camera maybe
some like a reflector and and you're
good everyone from la is taking these
instagram shots so that kind of like
made me a little bit cringy about the
idea of taking photos but then i'm
looking at the flowers i'm like they're
so pretty i should put a dress on and be
like everyone else i've been like
hopping around i'm like trying really
hard to like step on the areas that
don't are kind of like sparse already
because it's kind of sad to see a flower
die
under your foot i was actually maybe
this is like neurotic of me but i was
thinking of the caption that i was going
to write as i was coming up here don't
step on the flowers
i mean people have been generally on the
trails or like walking on the paths and
we were very protective of where we put
like any of our stuff because we don't
want to ruin it but i just feel like
people
ultimately won't be that respectful
though yeah so because they don't give a
[ __ ] about nature [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] about nature either the plant is
not just a flower
so even if you don't step on the flower
you might step on the plant
and when you watch these people try to
take these photos you realize how basic
and stupid they look i mean there was
nothing worse than watching people be
like
okay
you look dumb
it's embarrassing to just watch you i'm
already not a fan of selfies it's gonna
be [ __ ] i want to take selfies
all the time not really for it you know
take one stuff that's good all the
[ __ ] time
but just that to that extent ugh
that's the cringe of the cringe
there's moments that are passing and
you're just going to live your moments
through your phone yeah yeah you know um
i met a certain
person who's really well known
and um
me and the individual were having a
conversation we're just talking to
chatting and
you know like the fans started lining up
and everybody was like can i get a photo
can i get a photo and it just thought i
was so funny that everyone who was there
was more concerned with taking pictures
than getting it to actually know the
person that they admire rather than
getting in their head and like getting
some information or you know maybe
sharing something
they were more concerned with
look who i'm with i'm so high value
people's priorities are in a weird place
but that's my thoughts on it it's a real
world yeah really weird yeah oh that is
super weird yeah i've been taking
pictures and even fans coming up to me
and be like can i take a picture
it's weird yeah but sure i'll take it i
appreciate the fans who come up and like
hey man i really love what you do
i'm like thank you brother the ones that
you're doing the ones that have
questions
sure sometimes sometimes some long-ass
questions so my girl dumped me and i'm
like oh hell no this is not therapy
i'm trying to have a burger leave me
alone but uh you know generally some
people are mad cool hey man i appreciate
what you do much love i'm like thank you
i appreciate that too
so
yeah it's just an interesting
perspective that people have when it
comes to like stunting online and
needing to take pictures and all that
stuff but hey it's the age we live in i
guess so it is what well let us know
what you think are we too harsh i'm sure
there's a bunch of you guys who are
super basic who love to take all these
pictures yeah let us know why you do it
live you live your life live your basic
life specifically i'm talking to the
lakes am i lying no
no
not the photos of everything that's you
know why do you think they're ready for
tinder yeah
you know they documented everything in
my life i've been through a lot of
interesting stuff if i documented half
of it i'll probably have some of the
best photos also yeah but you know i'd
rather just live than just live it yeah
can you guys go on vacation once without
taking a single picture it's not even
possible is that possible no
[Music]
and for the guys that do it you know
maina
wait a minute
[Music]